Sáng nay, bụng tán tháng 2, tức ngày 25 tháng 9, tị, chú tích nước lưng cửa và phụ nhân, cù với đại biểu chính phủ,
quốc hội, ban bộ, nành trung ương, thành phố Hàn Nội và một chăm đại biểu kiểu bảo thư biểu, thực hiện gỷ lệ dân,
tại tượng đại vô lý thay tổ và đền gọc sân. Đây là hoạt động năm 2020,
xong quên khổ chương trình, xôn quế hơn 2.25 xong, xong y 반 nhé nước về người Việt Nam ở nước ngoài,
bộ ngoại sào, phối hợp với người bán nhìn dân thành phố Hàn Nội tổ chức thường niên,
hóa phần lát tỏa thông điệp về khối đại đàn kết bản dân tổ. Trong đó,
cộng đồng người Việt Nam ở nước ngoài là bộ phận không thách sời, luôn đồng hành cùng tổ quốc.
Đông thời thề hiện só tình cảm và chức giệp của đàng và nhận nước, trong việc trong lo cho cộng đồng người Việt Nam ở nước ngoài,
phát huy tình thành yếu nước, hướng vệng hồn cội. Lát tỏa nềm tin và hơi dạy khác phọng công hiến cho sự phát triển bên vững cuối đất nước trong gia đình mới.
Chong không khi chăng nghiêm, chú tích nước và phụ nhân, cùng các đại biểu kiểu bảo,
đả thành kiến dân hơn từ nếu công ân của được lý thay tổ và các vị tin hiện tin liệt, các vị liệt tổ liệt tông,
đá xây sự và bảo vệ thang loong hành động, nhìn năm và diễn,
dính giữ nó sông gấm vóc vệng năm anh không, bồi đáp những giả trị văn hóa,
lịch sự trên thống vô cùng cuối giá cho thủ đô và đất nước máy trường tôn.
Đồng thời, bây giờ, lòng thành kiến cầu cho cốt thái dân an, đất nước vững tiên bước vào kiến bên phát triển mới.
Tếp đó, chú tích nước và phụ nhân, cùng các đại biểu kiểu bảo, đả thăm ra hoạt động thả cá chép tại hồ hành kiến.
Sự kiện diễn phát, khi chỉ còn ít này nữa là đến ngày 2018,
mà theo trên thống lâu đời của người dân Việt Nam là ngày tiến ông công ông tạo châu chơi,
với mũ ý, cá chép vượt vụ mùa đoạn dòng, biểu tượng cho sự kiến chỉ và bên bị để hướng tự sự phát triển và thành công.
Chong không khi thân tình, hơn hoàn mừng đàn, mừng xôn mới, chú tích nước lưng cửng và phụ nhân,
đại chia sẻ với bảo con kêu bảo về tình hình công việc cuộc sống,
cảm ơn cộng đồng người Việt Nam ở khắp nơi trên thế giới,
đã luôn một lòng hướng về quế hướng đất nước, chú cho tất cả bảo con, một năm mới ăn hàng thịn vực thành công.